a year ago I sat here and championed to
resume I believe she was good and steady
and I wanted people to give her a chance
well she's had that chance and she's
blown it big-time her cabinet is in
revolt her own MPs nevermind the nation
thinks she's incapable of delivering
brexit and a new bosses see her as a
joke that they can walk on Twitter
Theresa May is responsible for the
crippling dysfunction in Downing Street
she's been told by the EU and her own
MPs her checkers plan and the know do
your backstop won't fly yet still she
refuses to change tack and now comes the
terrifying realization that she has no a
back-up plan
she's lost and we're once his
stubbornness was seen as the weapon was
which to deliver brexit it's now the
roadblock stopping it
the truth is Teresa may can't lead and
her lily-livered capitulation to the EU
has destroyed her credibility and any
chance of a good deal she has to go
Britain needs a robust leader who has
the guts to fight for a brexit that will
be good for us not the arrogant
contemptuous clams you well let's go
through this chronologically and to
remind viewers that on one paper list on
Sunday the Sunday Times yeah this
started language such as the killing
zone bringing your own noose whatever it
might be
knives and stabbing a pool appalling
language and I think it discredited
anyone who was involved as everyone
agreed then we turned to what happened
after that was published and speaking on
Sky News Conservative MP Robert health
and speaking disguise Sophie Ridge on
Sunday said this who is this magic king
or queen over the water that is suddenly
going to solve all the Conservative
Party problems and it doesn't matter if
it's treason May or Mother Teresa unless
we get our values right unless we are
seen by the public that we're on their
side and as we sought out the brexit
thing and actually unify as a party it
doesn't matter whose leader there's
there's no one as I can see who's got
some magic solution is going to solve
everything that's Robert helpful
speaking to Skye Sophie rich on Sunday
um and he
absolutely I get your frustration and
had we been saying this 12 months ago I
could possibly see what you're saying
but there are so many moving parts
we are almost you could say well we are
weeks away from one key deadline we're
days away from the the December summit
as well I cannot see what changing an
incredibly important moving parts such
as the PM will achieve and just finally
before I let us come in boat whoo-hoo to
quote Robert there who is this magical
prince or princess is going to come
galloping over the hill to put it right
we're in a bad place I don't dispute it
we're in a shocking place it's too
darned late so because we've got a PM
who is no good let's just hear what
Johnny Mercer said there this week
here's the Plymouth MP for more view he
said when all is said and done politics
is about people the lives of real people
are so a stage to prance around on in
London feigning strength and conviction
it requires courage fight and conviction
to meet the challenges before us we need
technocratic managers yes we couldn't do
it without them but at this defining
moment in our history Britain cannot be
led by him and this is the problem you
know the EU have humiliated us beyond
belief and she has let the EU control no
she's let the EU control regs and
negotiations from the start we go for a
meeting
they say off you go you've got a change
of proposal she goes back with
watered-down proposes it happens again
so what we're going to get with Teresa
mate is a fudge that serves no one and
someone we need we need to change tack
now before it's too much back to Nick's
point so who then I don't know spoiled
with with fantastic ideas but you know
they're saying that the position last
week was to line up an interim prime
minister to our exit well there's the
talk is of David Davis brick city
because she took him away from it now
Shane grooved negotiations are doing it
to go so wow you seem to me to have an
amazing ability to jump in the wrong
bandwagon
it's really well you say well you think
she's doing a great job I don't know I
think the thing is a disaster but I
think she's our only chance
yes my guess is what happened I mean the
problem is gonna be this she'll get a
deal
yes the ties us to this she'll get a
deal of some sort we then have a choice
or Parliament has a choice will I accept
her deal or not my choice I guess is
they won yes so then so then the choice
is between crashing out or something
everyone uses this term rushing out you
know it's it's it's you know they you
have to know that we're serious about
walking away and they never have been
because it's somewhat somewhat south
into it there was reports this week in
the paper when if the savage Javid such
a Javits had said to her have you ever
actually threatened that we would walk
away and the consensus was that she
never had the EU they're not gonna offer
us a goodly you know she says the deals
ninety-five percent and that's cause
she's capitulated on them alone like we
had the referendum we didn't have a
negotiating position that's the problem
that's not it is the moment where the
moment we said we're going to leave and
I as a politician I've got to leave
because this is what the people have
told me from that moment I had no
negotiation and they could just sit and
wait and that's what I've done a strong
leader and leader who said we don't want
a year ago I didn't say what June I just
said a year ago sat in this chair I
realized I've changed my mind because I
wanted people to give her a chance but I
didn't realize how bad she was gonna be
the truth is after she lost the election
having got a 20% lead in the polls the
truth says we should have got shot over
there when I when I think back to Italy
because she has no political judgment
yeah her critics say she doesn't listen
to ministers I I do think we're in a
pickle to put it mildly
my words carefully I do think we're in a
pickle and I feel very very disappointed
with the way that everything is playing
out at the moment but I don't believe
that the answer is yet more change
because if you went out into the street
and you said to many people
just outline some of the key post
holders of some of the key positions in
the cabinet they wouldn't know who holds
the post and one of the reasons is you
see it on telly so and so as Rosanna
it's all over the newspapers so-and-so
step down people on the street go whoo
hold on let me just make my point my
point is there is so much change
rotation in politics at the moment and
there's so much with this brexit thing
people are using this to further their
own personal agendas they're
backstabbing they're deliberately trying
to undermine they're slapping off to to
Brussels to have their own meetings when
it's not their job to be doing so you've
had so much change of key personnel that
what we actually need is some
consistently until you need to get
behind the 9020 it is like the trade
union Conservative Party if so many
people repel the PM so Nadine Doris will
who was at that meeting tweeted out that
meeting was all staged
she said check his loyalists actually
positioned themselves at various part in
the room and started banging the table
too faint what she wouldn't say that
just to frame can I just bring in a
video grab for Chris Grayling and this
is what he had to say in terms of those
are behind myths may Teresa may is very
clearly the woman in charge of these
negotiations she should have the support
of the party I think she has the
overwhelming support of the Conservative
Party and it's really important for the
country because although we've made
really good progress we've agreed 95% of
the withdrawal agreement we've made good
progress on the negotiations about the
future economic partnership there are
still some difficult issues and I just
have to say it's not often I agree with
a Tory MPs often I agree with Michele
but it's happened twice and this baby
something's going on I know so I just
want to pick up and what Nick said
earlier I think the way that some of
these backbench Tories have treated mrs.
Mays that feeling disgusting
and this is what Nicola Sturgeon had to
say she said this morning I've seen
quotes from Tories to the effect that
the MP is entering the killing zone
faces assassination should take her own
noose to a meeting few disagree with her
more than I do
but language like this did base his
politics get a grip totally agree with
that and what happened after that was
MPs who were who were you know gonna not
agree with her as the
twenty-two meeting they rally behind her
out of sympathy they're cool they're
naked they had to that's not the reason
to you they could they might be able to
have a vote too haven't got enough to
get rid of her the ones that don't like
it so better it let's just let's just
look at the woman herself okay look at
what she says before any decision I ask
how do i best deliver the brexit that
the British people voted for how do I
best take that control of our money
borders and laws how do i best protect
jobs and make sure nothing gets in the
way of our brilliant entrepreneurs and
small businesses and if doing those
things means I get difficult days in
Brussels then so be it
the brexit talks are not about my
interests they are about the national
interest and the interests of the whole
of the United Kingdom I've ended up
admiring her for her ability to just
take all the criticism all the attacks I
personally never vote for her but that's
not the point I think I think Shh
she's the tour his only chance of
everything she said she wanted for
Britain checkers does not deliver it
listen it has one commentator said this
week there's not a problem that this
woman can't make worse and in recent
weeks she's angered leavers and remains
alike because that checker still does
not give give also brags it it does not
give this this country the breaks again
we voted for